SINCE APPARENTLY NOBODY ELSE
WILL.
ALSO TONIGHT, THE INGRAM ANGLE
IS EXPOSING POOR LEADERSHIP LIKE
IN THE STATE OF NEW MEXICO.
WE DON'T TALK ABOUT THEM MUCH.
THEIR CITIZENS DESERVE BETTER.
THE STATE OF NEW MEXICO AND THE
CITY OF ALBUQUERQUE SUED THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION OVER ITS
ASYLUM POLICIES.
THE STATE WANTS TO RELEASE
ASYLUM-SEEKING MIGRANTS INTO
LOCAL COMMUNITIES AND THEN CLAIM
REIMBURSEMENT FOR HUMANITARIAN
EFFORTS TO SHELTER THEM.
JOINING ME NOW IS ANDREA MOORE,
SECRETARY OF THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY OF NEW MEXICO.
ALL RIGHT, ANDREA.
WHAT DO YOU SAY ABOUT THIS
SITUATION IN THE STATE?
>> I THINK IT'S DEPLORABLE TO
USE A TERM THAT WE ON THE RIGHT
HAVE BEEN GIVEN.
WE ARE COUNTIES, CITIES AND
VILLAGES JUST AT CAPACITY AND
THE LIMITED RESOURCES THAT THEY
HAVE ARE BEING STRETCHED THIN
BECAUSE THEY'RE BEING FORCED TO
HOUSE THE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
CROSSING OUR BORDER.
>> Laura: ANDREA, YOU AND I RAN
INTO EACH OTHER ON A PLAN.
WE DIDN'T KNOW EACH OTHER.
YOU TOLD ME THE STORY OF
NEW MEXICO, WHICH HAS BECOME A
SOLIDLY DEMOCRAT STATE.
THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION THINKS
THEY HAVE A CHANCE TO FLIP THAT
STATE BACK TO THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY.
GIVEN WHAT HAS HAPPENED UNDER
DEMOCRATIC LEADERSHIP ON THE
ISSUE OF IMMIGRATION, DO YOU
THINK THIS IS POSSIBLE?
>> OH, ABSOLUTELY WITH THE
CONTINUED FAILING POLICIES OF
OUR GOVERNOR, OUR STATE IS
PRIMED TO BE FLIPPED BACK TO RED